you got Darin ham giving hugs to Reggie
Miller got Austin Reeves with us here
Austin without LeBron James Anthony
Davis on the road against the best team
in the NBA how do you explain what just
happened tonight it's just a lot of
heart uh you know we come together as a
group before and we was just like look
you know our two best players aren't
playing the the least we can do is go
compete and that's what we did uh we
made shots we played the right way and
we really competed on the defensive end
how much did you guys take to heart
LeBron's comments after the loss in
Atlanta he said just go out and do your
job yeah that's I mean it's a great
message and uh you know coming from you
know the greatest player ever in my
opinion you know that's what we should
do and tonight you know I think that
shows that we you know listen and uh
we're ready to you know roll so what do
you take from this that you can apply
moving forward just playing the game the
right way and competing at 110% uh
that's the main thing when we do that
you know we've proven that we can beat
anybody uh we just got to eliminate
those games where we go out and just you
know kind of you know go through the
motions we got to go out there and
compete 110% every game and uh good
things will happen new season high for
Austin Reeds congratulations yeah I
appreciate
you